best piece of advice for someone looking  to get into ai machine learning  best piece of advice uh  i guess it depends who the person is  yeah um  i would i would maybe it depends yeah if  it's someone with like marginalized  characteristics or not i would give very  different advice if it was a woman i  would say don't listen to  like your supervisors telling you you're  not good at this  because everyone will get that or tons  of people get that don't listen to that  chances are you're just thinking about  things in a way that's different than  they're used to so uh have have  confidence in yourself  um i guess if it's someone with more  majority characteristics i would say  like forget about the pipeline problem  pay attention to the people around you  and make sure that you hold them up too  uh so that the pipeline problem that  you're in right now  uh is less of a problem  and i guess i would also say evaluate  your systems